- You were almost giving
up and working hard
as all artists do in the beginning,
and something made you not give up.
So, tell everybody what that was,
'cause it's amazing.
- Aww.
Yeah, so I'm like a year into Nashville,
and Nashville is...
I'm this young girl, I'm 18-years-old,
I have no clue what I'm
doing, where to start.
I'm about a year into town
and crumbling just day by day.
- Yeah.
- I called my sister
one day and I was like,
"Hey, I have no clue
what I'm doing out here."
It's just the whole, like,
if you come home, you
didn't fail, it's okay.
And that day, Taylor Swift was driving by.
I was leaving work,
and I was wearing this
Taylor Swift t-shirt
and she was just driving by
and saw saw me standing
there and was like,
"Hey! I love your shirt!"
- I love that she did this!
- I know!
And I'm like, what is my life, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it really-
- But she had no idea the
impact that that would make
'cause you were thinking of quitting,
and that had to have been like,
"This is a sign from God."
- Oh, it was crazy.
I'm like, "I'm quitting my
job, I'm quitting school,
and I'm gonna go figure this out.
I don't know how to do it,
but I'm gonna figure it out."
Like that doesn't even
happen, that doesn't happen!
- No, but sometimes you...
No, that does not happen,
that's the craziest story ever.
But I think it's so cool,
and telling of her character.
That's very cool that
she did that, for one.
And you have no idea
the impact you'll make on someone's life,
and how it will change their lives.